all right we are now live for the first
of our philosophy pop-ups for the month
of June I'm going to wait a little bit
well people arrive and before I do that
let me say thanks to all of my patreon
supporters who make this possible and
this month I'm going to focus on let's
call it issues of the body and how
things go right or wrong with the body
from a philosophical perspective or
rather perspectives I'm going to talk a
bit about the Stoics that about
existentialists bit about you know
Platonism and and cartesian dualism and
and also about aristotle so oh it looks
like we already have quite a few people
here a number of people saying hello
hello to all of you I've been thinking a
lot about the body
my son is you'll see him popping up from
time to time as he's trying to watch
this on the floor and not get in frame
my son is hoping to become a youtuber
himself and he actually helps me edit
videos and is now helping me edit some
of the podcast things as well so right
back to what I was talking about we've
had a lot of things going on in the
sadler shaka household in terms of
bodies and health and various
vulnerabilities we have two old dogs you
know 12 and 13 who you know really gone
beyond their life expectancy and things
are starting to go wrong in in different
ways so you know we're getting to see
that it's not as if I haven't seen that
with a lot of other pets before in the
past as if my wife hasn't but you know
it's staring us in the face daily I've
been working out quite a lot since
really about February you know trying to
get in anywhere from three to six
workouts a week and I'll talk about my
motivation for that in
it's very different in my 40s than it
was in my teens and twenties or even my
thirties but you know things are
actually getting better for me in terms
of like endurance and how much I can
actually exercise and physical lifting
and I've been doing physical therapy for
some things that I should have had you
know looked at a while ago but for my
wife things have been kind of rough
recently she tore her meniscus in an
exercise class of all places and then
you know tried to get through it and
finally went to the doctor and the
doctor looked at it and said yeah you
got torn meniscus so we started doing
that you know the regimen of no stairs
icing you know staying off of it as much
as possible and it's really tough for
her she can't catch a break when it
comes to this sort of thing because then
she she injured it even even worse and
you know at our age in our late 40s when
things start to get screwed up with you
know joints and all that there's no such
thing like as a for ligament as a
partial tear as I found out when I tore
two ligaments in my left knee several
years ago the doctor you know looked at
me and said yeah those exist for 20 year
olds it's pretty rare that you find them
for people in their 40s and so you know
I just go without - ligaments the
muscles adjust for it and I try to avoid
you know making sharp turns so that
maybe what we've got in store for her as
well and these are the sorts of things
that as you're getting older right you
have to start taking stock of and so
here's the philosophy part comes in I
think when it comes to what we can call
philosophies of life or practical
philosophies those sorts of things that
have to do with aging and injuries and
health in general are quite important
you know if we're thinking in terms of
say existentialism existentialism
focuses on the human condition and it
looks for the things that really do in
fact affect their lives the things that
we we are drawn to or pushed away from
the things that involve our passions by
the way not
looking for any any medical advice from
anybody here so I should have mentioned
that from the beginning every time I
post about this I get people you know
giving me all sorts of unsolicited
advice we're just fine yes with that so
but yeah so going back to sort of
thinking about things existentially and
the and this the existentialist we're
really doing the same sort of thing that
philosophers have been doing for for you
know two millennia thinking about the
things that really matter to the human
condition not just in terms of you know
theoretical topics but very practical
topics so how does how does the world
change for you when you can no longer
get around quite as well I mean you're
you know Heidegger has this great stuff
on mood and you know era I mean some of
it is actually coming out of Aristotle's
rhetoric Aristotle talks about this and
you know if you think about it the world
of the angry person is not the same
thing as the world of the the sad person
or the joyful person or the the person
who is focused primarily on care and
it's similar for encumbrances or for you
know like for myself as I'm regaining
strength that I haven't had for a long
time new things become possible the
world starts to get perceived in a
different way and so I wanted to talk a
bit about you know different ways in
which philosophy either takes account of
the body or totally discounts the body
and there is one question in there that
Robert is asking you know are we our
bodies or our minds so that's that's a
great jumping-off point right in some
ways we're both I'm if you want to ask
my view on it we are our bodies our
bodies are inextricable from who we are
but we're not just our bodies right the
mind is not simply reducible to the body
and you notice that even some of the
materialists that are out there some of
them will at least say well yeah the
whatever is going on is material but our
conception of materialism
is far too reductive if we think it's
what you know science can reveal to us
or something like that so the Stoics for
example you know our materialists but
they think that the what we call mind or
spirit or however you want to think
about it you know in Greek sookay and
and in Pima also you know in in Latin
animus if you if you think about those
sorts of things they would have to be
something material but they're not
something reducible to the material of
just what we look at as the body there
would be something more to it as well
and then of course you know at another
extreme we have dualistic positions like
that of Plato you know we're the body
and the soul or something really
different from each other it's a little
bit difficult to figure out exactly how
they interact that's one of the the big
problems for substance dualism not one
by the way I'm gonna try to resolve in
this this session here right because
there's a lot of people working on that
and and none of the solutions that
people have come up with have gained
universal consensus as being good ones
so you know if they can't do it I'm
certainly myself but it's if you know
that's another extreme position where
the body and the soul or in mind whoever
you want to call it are are separate and
and you know Descartes uses the metaphor
of the pilot in the ship you know just
sort of moving it around and if we adopt
that sort of position towards the body I
tend to think that there's there's a
plus side to it which is you know non
reductionism we're not simply saying
well whatever you've got going on with
you it's really a matter of what's going
on in your bodily States or your brain
States or something like that that's
good but it does tend to lead to
discounting how important the body is
for us and in particular the body that
we've got because you really only get
one of them and I you know there were a
lot of people when I was in my teens and
20s
like maybe don't exercise like that or
maybe don't do that sort of thing
because it's gonna have bad effect on
your body over time and of course my
answer to them was ah I'll be fine shut
up old person you know and now I'm that
old person who routinely winds up saying
I think they were right and sometimes
giving advice like that as well to other
people so yeah substance dualism that
tends to lead to discounting the body
interestingly it doesn't have to
somebody like Descartes was really
interested in looking at the body as a
very complex machine he you know we we
think of them primarily for like the
core G - ergo storm and all that that's
just the very beginning of the discourse
and the you know meditations you want to
read all the rest of the stuff because
what you notice him doing throughout
that is you know developing some sort of
basis for certainty for modern science
and he thought that if we could just get
the metaphysics right we get the physics
right and then from there we can get
three M's right which are mechanic's
medicine and morality and all of those
could be looked at in a sort of
mechanistic fashion which you know he
did he was in effect not just a
philosopher but a natural scientist you
know he carried out a lot of experiments
he he spent a lot of time trying to add
to our stock of knowledge not just in in
Natural Science too but also in
mathematics so you know dualism doesn't
have to lead to discounting the body but
often it does there's other ways of
looking at the body as well you know the
Aristotelian tradition well they always
had kind of a difficult time Aristotle
himself said that the the soul is the
form of the body and when the body dies
the soul itself is just going to end you
know maybe there will be a survival of
something called the active intellect
but that's really impersonal and that
there it gets very very murky anybody
who tells you that they know exactly
what Aristotle's position on that is be
asking you because you know I routinely
every year I go to the air
subtle conference here at Marquette
which is coming up this week or this
month later this month and we bat around
the ideas about this Aristotle scholars
themselves are not in full agreement
about it and then the Aristotelian
tradition you know gets gets absorbed by
various theistic thinkers who want to
you know have some sort of understanding
of the soul as being something more than
just the body or more than just the form
of the body and it takes a lot of work
to try to you know figure out exactly
how that's gonna work but you know we
have the interesting Muslim theologians
and philosophers tackling that we have
the poeltl mystic tradition there's
actually an incorporation of
Aristotelian ism and in other traditions
I'd like to also talk about the Stoics
you know the Stoics might be seen as
people who also discount the body
they're not substance duelists but they
really do place this priority on you
know the soul as opposed to the body
which is very Socratic right Socrates is
constantly saying focus on improving
your soul don't worry so much about your
body or your social position or things
like that and the Stoics also have this
thing called the dichotomy of control
that some of you are probably familiar
with which is one important doctrine but
not the only doctrine of stoicism and a
lot of people get the dot the the
dichotomy of control wrong because they
only read enchiridion one and and then
don't read the rest of the stuff that it
that Epictetus is saying about it here's
what the the dichotomy is right
Epictetus says some things are in or
control or inner power at Combe own by
the way a phrase that occurs in
Aristotle too in his discussions of
what's in our control and then there's
other things that are not in our control
right there and those would be things
like property or social position or any
of those sorts of things but epictetus
also includes our bodies why because our
bodies are sort of an interface there's
my son again crawling around you can see
him Matt just get up if you're gonna be
here so he's participating a little bit
in the session he's trained
how to frame but but not succeeding in
it so the Stoics you know they say the
body is something that's that's not
really in our control that doesn't mean
that we don't have any control
whatsoever it doesn't mean that we don't
control whether we eat crappy food or
eat good food exercise don't exercise
you know avoid like getting it injured
or anything like that and the Stoics
view the body is something that's
strictly speaking external external to
our minds but that doesn't mean that the
body doesn't in fact affect our minds
and it doesn't mean that we don't have
to take what they call care or attention
or you know have proper use crisis in in
greek of the body as a matter of fact
use of externals is something that's in
our control Epictetus says and it's very
central that we we attend to that sort
of thing so the Stoics would say listen
you know you get this one body and by
the way when when that dies that's
pretty much you dying i mean there's a
few like things speculations about maybe
parts of your body will survive
afterwards right but but in general you
know dying is that that's it
so you really ought to attend to it you
know correctly you shouldn't shouldn't
do things that are harmful to it you
know you should take care of it like you
would any other good instruments so that
it's it's handy when you when you want
to do something with it and you have to
understand that it's going to age and
it's going to to break down over time
existentialists also have very
interesting perspectives on the body and
you know the ones that like Gabriel
Marcel is somebody who I draw a lot from
and Marcel you know has this great
discussion about the difference between
being and having and he talks about our
body as not just something that we have
like you know you know possession we are
our bodies we're not just our bodies but
we do have to take account of of you
know the kinds of body
that we have and we need to attend to
them so health is something that you
would focus on from a philosophical
perspective if we're talking about
philosophy of life I know there's a lot
of philosophers out there who are you
know I'm going on terrible models for
that and on the other hand seemed not to
talk about that at all they talk about
it were just these you know disembodied
minds or you know these in these very
abstract ways but but that's you know
that's not everybody vulnerability to
this is something I'll start taking
questions in just a moment this is
something I wanted to to bring up in
this so you know the world will drive
home to you sooner or later the
vulnerability of your body to all sorts
of things our bodies are the interface
between us whatever we are and the
totality of existence and being able to
participate in existence means being
able to be hurt and damaged and
sometimes without even realizing it you
know I'll give you an example of
somebody who was wounded years and years
before she actually felt that a friend
of my mother's
Marci Butler she who my mother went to
school with she heard her Achilles
tendon when she was a girl and it never
quite healed up properly and she forgot
about it entirely and then when she was
in her 40s one day she was walking along
and it just snapped and her of course
you know if you if your Achilles goes
that's it for your leg for the time
being and of course she collapsed and
she was like what the hell was this you
know and you know she went to the doctor
and the doctor said not much we can do
about this unfortunately this was back
in the 1980s or 1990s maybe they could
do something about it now maybe they'll
graft a new one or something like that
but you know it really did not turn out
well for her she had to walk with a cane
and and all that and and you know how
would she know that that was latent
within her all this
this time there are so many things like
that where we don't really grasp until
it happens the vulnerability of our body
I'll tell you you know I mentioned that
my I'm missing to tend to ligaments in
my left knee we were out at Montauk on
the beach there's actually a video about
this way way back at you could take a
look at it if you want to and you know
we were in the spray and the waves are
kind of high and I turned because my
daughter was was you know coming to talk
to me about something and I was still in
it and I got hit by a wave and something
went the wrong way and suddenly I was in
terrible pain and I was getting washed
up on the beach and trying to get up and
the leg just going out from under me
because of course you know the me lost
two out of its four main main ligaments
so it was just flopping around and well
that was quite a shock you know and then
that also led to having to wear a brace
and walk with a crutch for an entire
semester and that really changes the way
that you look at things as well trying
to do grocery shopping with crutches you
know for example so I think that's
probably enough about that loan you
start scrolling up and looking at all
these great questions and comments
Andrew asks thoughts on meditation I've
tried it in the past I'm not much of a
meditator some people have a much easier
time doing that then than others you
know my mind tends to get particularly
active and I have indeed tried it I've
actually gone to classes and you know I
it just doesn't do that much for me if
I'm going to meditate on something I
need something that has a bit of
structure and you know so and then the
other trouble is I don't really find the
time to do all that much about it
Valdemar have you read Hans bloomin berg
lagina legitimacy of the modern age I
don't think I have all right Zana what
sort of advice would I give to someone
who truly feels they've lost interest in
their job and try to try something more
fitting to their body or mind well
that's a great question that's the sort
of thing where you know you know in
order to really give great you know
useful advice about it I would need to
know more about the person in their
situation and all that but I can't say a
few generic things I do think it's kind
of common to lose interest in jobs that
you're doing sometimes it's just for a
short amount of time sometimes it's like
permanent you you never regain that
interest and it's possible to do jobs
that you are bored by or hate for years
and years and years I know some of my
relatives did that you can do it out of
a sense of duty or because you need to
earn money but it takes a toll on you
and and it is a good thing to try
especially in our society where we do
have some degree of social mobility or
at least unilateral mobility where you
can move around and we're not like stuck
in some cast or guild or something like
that once and for all for the rest of
our life it is good to look at other
alternatives I think if you're you know
if you're doing that you don't want to
you know a lot of people this goes
Nationals for jobs but for relationships
and a lot of other things a lot of
people sort of like run from one crappy
situation into what appears not to be
one but on the surface looks to be quite
good but turns out to be another and
another and another so I think it's
important to select sit down and think
about what is it that you're actually
looking for what would make you feel
like you're engaged or enjoying things
by the way you know they did this survey
a few years back and found that
something like you know 80% of employees
here in the United States are not
engaged
meaning emotionally engaged in their
work and that you know good portion of
them actually hate the jobs that they do
so this is it is a real problem a real
issue and that can take a toll on your
body you know having to do work that you
find irritating or boring or something
like that you know not only does it
affect your mental state but it can lead
to all sorts of other things that people
overeating having snacks just to fill
the time or doing you know habits that
could be destructive to their bodies or
their minds or just you know some
respects falling in with the wrong crowd
at work you know people who are also
Downers and they're like this place
sucks
you know I've seen that happen a lot in
the academic situations so so good it's
a good question
Alejandro asks what are my thoughts on
fucose archeological method I've been
reading a lot of his work and finding
him quite interesting if you read lame-o
either shows or the order of things yes
I studied him back in graduate school
and actually demonstrated to the class
that you know despite his claims to not
be a structuralist Foucault actually
uses a gram Ossian square in the order
of things without attributing it to
grimace so what about what do I think
about his archaeological method you know
I think that Foucault often has
interesting things to say I think that
you almost never want to take Foucault
as providing us a full perspective on
things I mean I don't know how many
criminologists you know have that you
know I had say to me that well
discipline and punish is great for
talking about a few prisons it's not
helpful and actually screwed up the
discourse when it came to many other
prisons as well and you know I think
that the order of things and the
archaeology of knowledge because we're
really talking about that that period of
time they're interesting works and I
think Foucault is somebody who you can
sort of partially appropriate the most
interesting work that gets done using
Foucault is usually not by philosophers
but by like sociologists and city
planners and people like that who use
some of his ideas and then and say yeah
the rest of this stuff we're gonna throw
this crap out so yeah Adam do you know
why Socrates says he knows nothing
because there's nothing to know Socrates
is free from the illusion of knowing no
Socrates only
that that you know he he knows that he
knows nothing and in that very dialogue
he also shows that he knows all sorts of
other things so you have to take that as
an ironic statement so many people have
made far too much out of that and
they've been you know carelessly
attending to only that part of the text
the part that they liked and not paying
attention to all the other places in the
texts where Socrates says well as we all
know right and I may agree with them so
yeah I mean if you want to be that sort
of uber skeptic that's great
but it's sort of like solipsism you got
to do that on your own nobody else is
really gonna do much of that with you
all right
Reid do you think Chomsky is right in
his commentary about the limits of human
understanding or science overly
optimistic how do we improve the
dialogue between philosophy and science
so I can't really say much about the
Chomsky stuff it's been years since I
read him I never found him when it came
even to the linguistic stuff to be all
that interesting you know I mean there's
sort of his linguistic stuff and
consciousness stuff and then there's the
the politic stuff his politic stuff is
more interesting but he's basically you
know just a hard leftist who you know
it's an equal opportunity critic of both
sides which is great you always know
exactly where he's coming from
you can often predict what he's going to
say when it comes out now our scientists
overly optimistic sometimes it depends
on what you're what you're asking about
they seem you know it depends on the
scientist and it depends on the
discipline but yeah some are overly
optimistic about what science is going
to achieve for us but that's been going
on for you know five hundred years part
of the problem is that scientists and
this is not just about scientists or
even stem people the humanities
disciplines are terrible with this as
well they often haven't read enough they
often don't know the history of their
discipline and they don't realize when
they're sort of replicating the same old
thing that was done with this movement
back in the 1850s where
if you looked at that and you're like oh
that's how they wound up in a dead end
and here's what we're saying that it's
just a new version of that maybe we
should be careful about this like I said
that doesn't just happen in the sciences
though that happens the humanities
happens all the time in education
happens all the time in business it's
kind of a you know human condition you
know santiana
it gets quoted those who you know don't
remember history are doomed to repeat it
and that's true the it's not just
they're doomed to repeat it
they're also doomed to repeat it and not
realize that they're doing the same damn
thing just under different guys and that
it's probably gonna have not exactly the
same results but it's going to hit the
same cul-de-sacs and dead ends so yeah
you know optimism by itself isn't a bad
thing well it often sort of drives
science we might even talk about a
certain faith that scientists have which
Nietzsche was really great at diagnosing
in his works Nietzsche saw the scientist
is essentially the new theologians and I
think he's still right about that how do
we improve the dialogue between
philosophy and science well that's a
good question I would say that a good
portion of that depends on further study
you know like like scientists need to
actually read some philosophy and not
just read it to get it get it read and
get it done and have some talking points
but they actually thoughtfully read it
and philosophers for their part need to
know what the hell they're talking about
when they are straying into other areas
you know they need to philosophers
probably also need to avoid you know
doing those sort of gotcha stuff very
clever you know little articles on this
and that because that's that's not
really helpful for anybody or nowadays
opinion pieces right but I don't have a
lot of great suggestions for that the
one thing I will say is every discipline
there's no such thing as philosophy and
science to begin with there's
philosophies and all sorts of Sciences
and within those Sciences there's all
different you know approaches so
you know it's very difficult to
generalize about these things as a whole
I mean you might say the same thing
about philosophy and theology or you
know anything else I mean even
philosophy and food studies right food
studies itself is a heterogeneous set of
disciplines put together so it often
depends on on you know which models were
we're looking at all right there's a
thing about Tai Chi in here it's I'm
gonna skip over my son Matt is triming
in saying nice things thomas writes d do
you think there has been a kind of
christian moralistic denigration
devaluation of the importance of bodily
well-being and beauty in favor of the
soul worth reasserting its aesthetic
importance and importance for eudaimonia
life I wouldn't call it Christian I mean
you can you can denigrate the importance
of bodily well-being in beauty from all
sorts of perspectives and I mean if you
want to associate it with particular
movements within Christianity sure I can
I can agree to that but if you're gonna
just say it's somehow Christian in some
giant essence of Christianity sense I
think that's that's probably bad in
history of ideas because you can find as
many counter examples in in various
Christian strains of thought and
practice as well is it worth reasserting
the aesthetic importance of the bodily
well-being and beauty no it's worth
refining it because there's already in
our culture a massive emphasis on that I
mean think about how many glossy ads
there are in magazines showing you these
models that have essentially almost
alien to human human nature potties
right as an ideal and the poor kids and
you know older people too who
internalize these these ideals and we
got like we've got them for everybody
right we've all we've got every sort of
niche covered you you're into like you
know bodybuilding
there's muscle and fitness for you right
you're into like you know decking
yourself out and clothes well there's
there's this magazine I don't know you
know which one it would be no we we
already have enough emphasis on it it's
a matter of getting it right it's a
matter of steering it away from sort of
unrealistic ideals and towards more
realistic goals and thinking about the
interface between body and mind that
goes beyond just like you know going to
yoga classes and doing namaste to people
and you know silly silliness like that
but actually thinking about I mean if
somebody tells me oh I practice yoga you
know my first thing is great what do you
think of Patanjali and they're always
like patan what is that like a netipot
and you know
Patanjali wrote the yoga sutras right so
if you're doing yoga you probably should
read about the ethical discipline yoga
but but a lot of people aren't but we
could be bringing we could be bringing
some new emphasis to that you know and
it could reach out to all sorts of areas
you know I mean I you know I look at
exercise now myself is something that I
do so that my bones are going to remain
dense and my muscles will not atrophy
and perhaps even regain enough strength
for me able to be able to handle the
situation's of life that I have to do
like carrying a dog down stairs when
there's a fire alarm or you know being
able to throw my my son up on top of my
shoulders or moving boxes when I need to
yeah and I think that sort of thing for
me at my age is probably much more
important than having a six-pack but
when I was in my 20s that sort of thing
mattered to me and but we could ask what
why do you want a six-pack what does
that signify to you what how does that
interface with the rest of your life are
you doing exercises that are just trying
to bring out you know you know sort of a
refinement and or are you doing
something that actually reflects genuine
bodily health because you know trying to
get a six-pack could be either either
way right I mean you see these guys who
do this this work you know with machines
or with free weights and they're trying
to like just work on this one
little muscle here and you're like man
you could be spending that time like
doing a useful exercise not something
that's just for sure
but you know if you say it like that
you're probably not going to get them
there's there's probably better ways to
do it so is there you know the gun going
back to this worth reasserting its
aesthetic importance yeah
and importance for eudaimonia life I
think when people are getting caught in
those things it's because they don't
they don't have a good understanding of
what eudaimonia or happiness would
really be and you could say well they
need to learn yeah but who's teaching
them or are they getting introduced to
that by the people doing professional
philosophy not much unfortunately are
they getting it from the popular culture
not often they're usually getting bad
messages instead so you know we could
think about is there a role for that all
right let's go on Reed do you have
advice on how to stay focused on life
goals and I focused I mean a more kind
of devotion than short-term focus so a
longer-term thing yeah there's a couple
things I could say one is it really is
helpful to find other people who share
those goals and and view them as
important so you can prop each other up
and have accountability and have you
know somebody else who you can talk with
about those things not just about your
successes but about your failures and of
course you don't want somebody who's
like oh you failed alright you want
somebody who's actually going to be
supportive but who's going to hold you
accountable so that's one thing another
thing is you know for a lot of people it
can be very helpful to write these
things out or put you know like a poster
on the wall and I'm not talking about
like a motivational poster I'm talking
about like something where you would
actually chart out your goals and and
think about your your biggest goals and
then how all these you know smaller we
could call operational goals actually
fit in with it and you can remind
yourself of where you want to be you can
also you know do the opposite to and say
remind yourself of where you don't want
to be or where you
don't want to be stuck you know the
things that you don't want to fall into
I'll give you an example right so the
the weightlifting for me I do the
circuit training right and I'm not I'm
not doing free weights or something like
that because I'm interested in getting
and doing my weight stuff getting out of
there because I got stuff to do and I
don't find lifting weights all that
interesting anymore like I used to when
I was young
why am i doing it well it's primarily
for you know making sure my bones stay
in good shape and building some some
muscle that I'm going to need for the
stuff that I'm doing and I can remind
myself well if I don't do that then I'm
probably not gonna live as long and the
life that I have when I'm in my 60s and
70s is not going to be as productive or
as pleasant because I didn't take care
of myself so if you do that sort of
thing I think that can be that can be
helpful maybe you set a certain time
every day to remind yourself of what
your goals are and think about how how
you're making them you know how you're
doing with your goals you know all right
democritus dr. Sandler for someone who
has a great deal of frustration and
organizing there's the key word my
literary philosophical and theological
studies do you have any advice for an
ariadne's thread so unfortunately I do
not and let's talk about the ariadne's
threads like so that Ariadne was was the
daughter of my nose my nose you should
associate with the Minotaur right the
Minotaur was at the center of a maze
called the labyrinth designed by
analysts and by a little sidenote
after the mine it took the Minotaur his
dad died analyst and his son Icarus are
gonna be imprisoned in the labyrinth now
ariadne's thread Ariadne gives Theseus
like a ball of twine or yarn or whatever
whatever it was and he leaves a little
thread behind him so he can find his way
back out of the maze after he's killed
the Minotaur
is there an aria a Deniz threatened like
that for studying unfortunately no the
world is much more complicated
oftentimes it is also sometimes called a
royal road right another things another
metaphor you will never find a way of
organising your studies that is not to
some degree arbitrary and that's okay
human knowledge and and sort of human
reflection on the world and ourselves is
so immense and complicated and so self
referential that any organizational
system that we come up with is always
going to be imperfect to some degree
you're always gonna be like I don't know
if this belongs over here or it belongs
over here you just have to have some
sort of way of organizing it so you can
find what you need when you need it and
you don't go nuts we it's more pragmatic
than anything else so but I under Title
II understand the motivation because I
don't know how many times I've
reorganized bookshelves for example
right or you know my papers or things
like that so I understand that
frustration Kanaga LV is it fair to say
Aristotle view is working out as an act
of bravery or courage I don't I don't
know that Aristotle would necessarily
say that I mean it could be something
you could say it's it's it could be like
an integral part of a larger act of
courage courage could also be involved
but you know here's some examples right
if you you have very bodily conscious
and you know it's sort of feeling
insecure about how you look
which I've certainly gone through myself
you know I'm overweight I'm older you
know especially when you start working
out you know you see these people doing
exercises and your
just to do a little bit of it right here
you know you're on the elliptical and
you're huffing and puffing away while
these other younger people are you know
really going to town you know like that
could bother you that could give you a
sense of fear a sense of embarrassment
and like pushing through that that could
require some courage so I guess that
could sometimes be it but but you know
routinely working out probably not
you think of it more as like developing
the instrument that you're going to need
for your courage which is your body
right and your capacity to endure
[Music]
now would Stoics view it as courage so
the stoic conception of courage is a
little bit different than the
Aristotelian one I mean the stoic
conception of virtue is more is
different - it's not always it you know
mean between extremes although sometimes
it is for Cicero and Seneca there's sort
of an often thing like you're virtuous
or your vicious there's nothing in
between that's very different than
Aristotle and the stoic a conception of
courage is quite broad courage or
fortitude right Andreea or fortitudo in
Latin and Greek so pushing through the
difficult exercises would in fact be be
courage for the stalks not a huge you
know example of it but some air subtle
you know the place to look for a
discussion of this would would be in
book seven in the Nicomachean ethics
because Aristotle talks about endurance
keratea which means you know it's sort
of the the mirror image of katia
self mastery karate is strictly speaking
with respect to pleasures not being
mastered by pleasures kaunteya endurance
is the same thing but with respect to
paints and working out it's not like you
you get in the machine you're like oh my
god
like you know this is so pleasurable I
can't keep myself from doing another set
yeah that's it
you're like oh geez can I can I actually
get through this set can I do the 12
reps I'm supposed to do you know now
I've got another set after this it's
dealing with pain or or trouble right so
all right Adam what are the difficulties
of learning Greek is it necessary to
learn ancient Greek to read Plato and
others I mean not really I mean if you
want to read Plato there's plenty of
great translations out there you just
got to be able to trust the translation
you can compare different translations
against each other learning Greek is
like learning any other language you got
to put in a lot of time and and you know
it's there there are things that are
going to be unfamiliar to you as an
English speaker you know like the case
structure it's great to do it because
then you learn a lot of you know stems
you learn a lot of grammar that actually
does apply to English and other
languages and you know if you like if
you're doing indo-european languages and
you learn Greek it's going to be easier
for you to learn Latin or easier for you
to learn German
whether it's contemporary German or what
they're it's like you know you know any
of the older languages like gothic or
you know middle high german or stuff
like that but you know you got to put in
time every day there's different methods
for doing it they don't all work out the
same for different people I'm a bit you
know I'm a bit of an outlier when it
comes to that so what works for me
probably won't work for a lot of other
people so I don't have a lot of great
advice for that Andrew I've just
recently discovered your channel and
can't thank you enough
thanks it's very nice of you to say that
so glad that you enjoy it
that's what at Bull's it might be
pronounced right Adil does okay why do
they call you the Minotaur of Milwaukee
the day there is people on 4chan
I don't know anybody outside like me at
the Minotaur of Milwaukee other than my
wife who thinks it's very funny it's in
part because
I am a big guy and there are some some
photos where usually I'm like standing
next to somebody who's smaller and I
look very large right and I am a big guy
six foot three
you know I am close to 300 pounds since
I've been working out by the way I have
been like shedding fat and gaining
muscle and have lost zero pounds you
know I've just got closer to 300 and so
maybe that's part of it maybe it's also
something to do with the maze
you know notion that I helped get you
through the maze
although the Minotaur doesn't help get
you through the maze the mentor kills
you in the middle of the maze so I'm not
sure that's such a great thing but it's
kind of a cool thing somebody created
they must have photo shopped at photo
with me lecturing one of my very first
lectures and they put a Minotaur hat on
there so that's can't just kind of a fun
thing you'd be better to ask the guys
who actually started doing that but I
don't know if you can figure out who
that is all right Tomica is dr. Sadler
just skipped up a bit
is it possible to conceive of such a
thing as revolutionary stoicism there's
Cato but I'm thinking of someone that
wants to change the world there's plenty
of revolutionary stomachs out there you
know there's funny
so stoicism itself stresses justice and
we're constantly having these
discussions within the stoic forums
about should stoicism be left wing or
right wing or something like that my
answer is it shouldn't be any wing just
like Aristotelian ism if you're an
Aristotelian you're not going to be
happy with either of our current parties
or with the left or the right but you
are gonna work your ass off for making
the world a better place and you're
probably going to have to ally from time
to time with various you know less
philosophical more ideological people
you know posing themselves in different
places in the culture and political wars
that we're going through right
I mean Cato is not revolution
Cato was in many respects a conservative
right he wanted to preserve the Republic
he at one time was willing to go and
kill solo and he was a young kid but it
is certainly possible to combine
stoicism to some degree with things that
people would consider revolutionary I
think that the very act of being a
virtue ethicist
and you know trying to practice that
sort of thing is inherently
revolutionary but it's not revolutionary
on the spectrum that people are used to
but that's that's that's my take Nicola
Nicola
what about hedonism and Epicurious yeah
it's a good question so Epicurus thought
that the body and the mind you know
again materialists like the Stoics but
we can distinguish bodily and mental
pleasures mental pleasures
Epicurus thought are much better much
more important mental pains are much
worse
so that's where we should be putting our
emphasis we care for the body so that we
can have as pleasant and prudent and
just a life as possible that's really
the epicurean tradition right there and
there are quite a few contemporary
Epicureans out there it's it's not as
big as the modern stomach movement but
it's big it's bigger than the modern or
stealing our plate mass movement right
so that that's that's well worth looking
into Reid given this talk about hurting
your body there's also ample scientific
evidence sedentary lifestyles are
correlated somewhere health problems
later on is an exercise still better
nobody said exercise wasn't still better
so I'm not sure what this is about
exercise often does hurt but it hurts so
that you could build if you're doing it
to the point where you're just hurting
yourself probably doing it wrong you
know so yeah you should you should
exercise I mean there there were some
people who have thought like you you
only start out with a certain amount of
like bodily energy and so don't use it
all up and I mean that just turns out to
be wrong physiologically
if you have that point of view and that
was right then probably you shouldn't
exercise but we know now that you you
should alright Democritus how did the
medieval and renaissance Christians take
care of their bodies assuming the
inherit of the ideas of Plato that's a
big assumption there they didn't inherit
the ideas of Plato many of them you know
exercised you know a lot of them
exercised just by virtue of not having
cars to drive them around or you know
having manual labor to do so you know
then there's like personal hygiene it's
kind of a myth that nobody bathes during
Middle Ages
you know all you got to do is read some
medieval literature to realize that
that's not that's not true at all I mean
different people do different things you
know this is something that somebody
could write an entire book on and I'm
sure somebody has out there Jeff
anything in Plato on diet or exercise
Platonism seems of a pretty negative
image of the body at Plato himself was a
wrestler I mean it's not a negative
image of the body it's a it's a it's a
view that the body is kind of a trap for
the soul and so you do take care of it
anything in Plato on diet or exercise
yeah there's plenty of discussions about
about diet throughout the the dialogues
you'll see it referenced almost
constantly medicine is the discipline
that handles that I mean the gorgeous
actually makes a big distinction between
medicine and cookery so probably want to
look around in there and the Republic
has discussions of diet and exercise as
well
you know for these guardians so yeah
there's tons of stuff but then there's
you know there's Plato and then there's
the Platonic tradition right so you
could also look at Plutarch Plutarch is
a plate inist
filo of Alexandria is a neoplatonist you
know see what they have to say there's
all sorts of interesting things
Jr I don't understand how the Stoics can
think we're not our body or some
synthesis of body and slow we die
without it and have to admit that health
drugs etcetera can impair mental
faculties I think you must have misheard
the Stoics don't think we're not our
body we're not just our body right we
are material there's also something
called which they called P alma or
spirit and that's also material and
that's also within us we're not just the
body as a scientific medicine
understands it obviously the Stoics
think that the body affects the you know
the mind and vice-versa all you gotta do
is read around a little bit in there and
they certainly admit that health drugs
etc impaired mental faculties and vice
versa you know if you're using drugs who
decided to use them but I mean that's
not even this is the Stoics Aristotle
would say that sort of thing so alright
something here about breathing I was
gonna skip over that alright here's
something from ariseth fun so I was
thinking about the relationship between
a philosopher in his body the usage of
the body is a device of hermeneutics so
interpretation right sometimes
historians of philosophy do emphasize
the body effects on the philosopher like
a Nietzsche's case do you think all
historians of philosophy should do more
of that no different historians of
philosophy are working on different
things some some are just trying to
elaborate the sort of coherent internal
structure of the ideas some are trying
to make cases about how social dynamics
are affecting a philosopher's thought
and vice versa some are interested in
you know much more biographical things
and those who are interested in that may
focus very much on the body some of them
may focus less you know I think it's a
mistake to try to reduce people to their
their biography you know people say well
Nietzsche had syphilis
this time and that's why he wrote this
stuff well people also said that about
Meryl Aponte's visible in the invisible
he wasn't getting enough blood to his
brain those are so so reductive and
they're not borne out by the texts you
know they're not borne out by what we
see there's no you know intrinsic
relation between having this disorder
and writing this sort of thing William
James by the way as a great piece
discussing that he himself had a mental
breakdown at one time you'll find
discussion of that in his riot ease of
religious experience as well as on other
things as well but yeah is should we
interpret things in terms of the body
yeah except that you know we don't have
access to people's bodies who have been
dead for like that so that's that like
we you know we get these very broad
brush depictions of them think about
Socrates for example you know a lot of
endurance could stand the heat in the
cold never got drunk even though he
drank as much as everybody else you know
ugly short squat all the sort of stuff
does that really tell you that much
about him I mean Nietzsche himself does
engage in quite a bit of this well this
is where Socrates ideas came from
because he was this and that that's
that's one of the weaker aspects of
Nietzsche's work I think the reduction
to you know these just temperaments or
bodies or things like that let me go on
Adam what are your thoughts on Taoism do
you think reducing our
self-consciousness can make our lives
easier so two different questions Taoism
is an interesting tradition which I've
taught you know and when I teach world
religions classes or Eastern religions
lost for classes which I haven't done
for a while it's it's not you know it's
one that you there's so many Taoist
texts out there classic Taoist texts
that you could spend the rest of your
life reading them it's not just the you
know doubted Dao de Jing and the drums
or something like that there's all this
other great stuff out there but I'm
myself only scratch the surface in it
and it's not something I'm really
attracted to you know so I don't have a
lot to say about it
do I think reducing our
self-consciousness can make our lives
easier it depends on the life and it
depends on the self-consciousness some
people need to be more self-conscious I
think some people need to be less some
people need to be self-conscious to the
same degree that they are but perhaps
about different stuff or in a different
way so I don't think that just reducing
our self-consciousness is a panacea for
the problems of our lives core ball I
worked in a gas station for six months
doing openings from 4:00 a.m. to 13 p.m.
1 p.m. full-time it was really
exhausting I didn't have the energy to
do anything after work except drink and
sleep yeah I work jobs like that myself
I worked there just third shift security
you know worked a lot of weird shifts I
worked in a gas station second shift and
same sort of deal but it could also be
the work I mean working in a gas station
slash convenience store not a not a fun
job really a lot a lot of weird stresses
you know that you get alright um let's
see here me Amy
0:07 most overrated philosopher of all
time in your opinion man that's that's
kind of tough to say I mean I don't know
I wouldn't know who to to place in that
that's a great question though who is
the most overrated philosopher of all
time I mean I think that at any given
time there's usually a lot of people
that are getting a lot of press and
being talked up a lot this is again a
historical perspective just reading
reading a lot in in the history of ideas
is quite important you see that there's
people who are like being stuff in their
own time and now nobody except for a few
you know
scholars talk about them at all and
that's pretty frequent that happens
generation after generation after
generation
so yeah Adam how would you define wisdom
I'm not a definition guy and I generally
don't don't try to do stuff like that so
there's plenty of definitions out there
Seneca we were just reading one recently
in the stoic fellowship but you know you
I don't have one for you what color are
my eyes green you know the sort of
brownish green oh here's a good one from
junior did Epicureans really believe a
wise man on the rack and the bulla
phalaris would say how delightful this
is how little I care for it or was that
tongue-in-cheek I think that's more
tongue-in-cheek than anything else
because I mean the bullet florist's for
those of you don't know it was a torture
device and it was a bowl that you'd
stick a human being into and then you'd
basically roast them from the you know
you put a fire and it roast them inside
of it and there's screams worse you know
there was a musical apparatus set up in
such a way their screams came out
sounding like beautiful music or
something like that and florists
apparently was one hell of a jerk you
know I think yet one point he wound up
in his own bowl which is you know not
quite poetic justice given how many
victims he had but yeah I think that I
mean the Stoics also you know are saying
stuff like that I don't think they're
really either they they were really
convinced of that
in which case that's pretty implausible
or you know maybe it was kind of joking
around all right
I'm gonna skip through some of the
joking that's going on here which is
perfectly fine
0:45 Sartre is influenced a lot by
Heidegger where do you agree more assort
than his influence for being in time and
other Heidegger works where do you agree
more with Sartre and then his influence
for being in time I'm not quite I don't
from being in time okay
well so I'll just say one one thing
right off the bat so start and you you
know if you read like heidegger's letter
on humanism you'll see how do you're
criticizing saturd about this Sartre is
much more human eccentric he really does
think existentialism is a humanism and
when Heidegger finds out that
existentialism that started as using
existentialism that way he's like I
don't need the word you you go ahead and
use it you keep it start by the way kind
of did that with with other people
Gabrielle Marcel ends up saying Sartre
is so you know so taken over the word
I'm not gonna bother using it I'm just
gonna call what I do you know philosophy
of existence or Christian socratis ISM
or something like that with Sartre there
definitely is a much more concerted
focus on the human being is the locus of
things
Heidegger thinks that that's kind of a
mistake the earlier work is much more
Humana centric a later work it's much
more about how we get out of our own way
in relating to being which is why I
think Eastern philosophers sometimes you
know saw connections between Heidegger
and and various ways of looking at
things say in Chinese philosophy and
Japanese philosophy but yeah I mean
that's probably about enough for this
because there's a lot of other things I
mean Sartre says that that Heidegger
didn't quite get nothingness right
that's in the the very early part of
Being and Nothingness
there's stuff about exercise that people
are writing I'm gonna skip over Oh
signor Pomodoro what do you think of
Anthony Kenny's position that the you
Demian ethics is the more mature work of
Aristotle's ethics more mature that is
then the nikah McKean ethics I don't
really have a view on this but let's
let's sort of summarize this for and and
what the the controversy is for people
who aren't familiar with this
so there's there's a general consensus
among Aristotle scholarship that wants
to say that the you Damien ethics he
wrote two different ethics the adamian
ethics and the naked mchao ethics and
three of the books of those two ethics
are the same but they they do differ and
like they're the books at the start and
the books at the end most of the
Aristotle scholars who actually take a
position on this I'm not a scholar who
does take a position but most of them
who do take a position think the nikah
McCain ethics is the more mature work
that that Aristotle was still more
influenced by Plato at the time that
he's writing the adamian ethics and
their evidence for this is usually like
well you know he he didn't talk about
this and he talked about this in a more
platonic way Kennedy says no the adamian
ethics is actually more mature it's
showing greater development in some ways
I'm always suspicious of these arguments
from development in part because I you
know look they are often quite circular
in terms of stylistics and you know what
we're supposed to be looking for there
by the way Plato scholarship is terrible
on there right the early dialogues
middle dialogues late dialogues I mean
we can agree that some of them
definitely are late some of them are
definitely early but where the hell the
rest of them fit in tough to say I think
that for me I'm less interested in
saying which is the more mature work I'm
interested in taking Aristotle's works
and reading them systematically so the
you Damien and Nicky McKay in ethics
I'm if I'm working on Aristotle's views
on friendship I'm drawing on both of
them and the politics
Amitha pics and the the rhetoric because
I don't want to leave stuff up right I'm
not just gonna be like well only the
most mature works for me you know but I
think there's a lot of people who are
that that way so oh right
I'm not sure
Stan this question Mimi 0/7 do you agree
with critics of Germany for making
statues of Marx I mean you make statues
of anybody you like I guess but I don't
know their recent statues that people
are worked up about can I talk about
about body image and what role it should
play in your lifestyle well that's a
good question
right so everybody's got a body image
and it can be very distorted right
people who you know want one there's
there's a thing called body just morphia
it's a psychological disorder called it
by different things and different things
in different diagnostic manuals because
not everybody uses the DSM there's
different traditions across the world
but the idea is that you look at
yourself and you see something that's
not there so I could have a body
dysmorphia of like looking at my nose
and thinking my nose looks like crap you
know it's so it's so squat right like
let's say I'd actually see it and it's
kind of squished in like this but it's
not really it looks just the way it does
I'm just having a distorted view of it
that's that's a real problem and a lot
of people like look in the mirror and
they they're you know very buff and they
think I'm so skinny or they look in the
mirror and they're very thin and they're
like god I'm so fat or I'm ugly or on
this or that and being able to to you
know actually see yourself as you are
that's pretty important the other thing
that I think is really important is
having realistic expectations about your
your body image you know and we live in
a society that's constantly feeding us
crap models for what are our body image
ought to be so that's that's a
significant issue and that does lead to
health problems I mean sometimes it
leads to over-exercising it leads eating
disorders it leads to people you know
having all sorts of anxiety which
prevents them from getting good sleep so
yeah
let's see here we're going a little
but I'll try to address the questions
I've got left how do I counter this from
Valdemar how do you counter the common
idea conclusion of disregarding all the
work the thinker just because some of
what they say is absurd being a product
of our time I at this point in my career
I just ignore people who do that because
it's not worth the time I limit the time
it's not worth the time for me to try to
convince them that you know that's a
foolish position to take very often
you're not going to actually reach them
I mean if you want it like let's say you
have a friend or a classmate or a family
member and you really want to invest the
time in doing that you just say listen
you're committing a fallacy by doing
this right and you can look in the
fallacies and see which one it is might
be a variation of an hominem could be
you know insufficient sample if you're
thinking about it inductively so yeah
Bailey would you be willing to speak on
Schopenhauer's influence on Nietzsche as
well as the relevance of Schopenhauer in
studying philosophy so much more early
on stuff you know the birth of tragedy
clearly influenced by Schopenhauer you
know there's references to Schopenhauer
in there the notion of music is being
sort of the thing that you're going to
get at the metaphysics with but I think
over time you know I mean the notion of
will as being central to is is also
pretty important but over time it you
know there's less and less influence I'd
say advice for someone finally embracing
their passion for philosophy in their
mid-20s do I know any other late
bloomers perhaps colleagues or
acquaintances who found themselves in a
similar situation many many many people
some of them are my students you know in
fact you know when you look at the the
comments on the YouTube videos there's a
lot of people in that boat who couldn't
study philosophy or when they did study
philosophies with some some jerk who you
know taught an intro class and talked
down to the stood
some didn't want to help them out with
anything and like turn them all off on
it you know so here yeah a bit of advice
as a matter of fact I did a guest blog
post and an interview with Lea goldrich
about this recently so I would take a
look at those it's like under ten
philosophical works you should read but
there's also some other stuff in there
as well some good advice don't expect to
read everything you don't have to read
everything you can't and expect to read
and reread and reread and you know if
you don't understand it at first that's
a-ok
that's that's par for the course that's
that's the way it works you know some
days I get in front of the chalkboard
and I've got all the notes on the on the
board and I've got my book in front of
me and I'm like I lost my train of
thought and I can't figure out what I'm
actually saying here Frances I feel like
a lot of philosophers are content to
spin their wheels of mediocrity they
don't even want to push their
intellectual achievements a higher level
how can we go further I don't know that
there's like a single answer to that I I
myself I get a lot out of reading other
people and seeing what they have to say
I don't think it's it's awfully
important to try to strive to be
original there's so many great thoughts
out there you know just being able to
understand what Aristotle is actually
saying and see the world for a while
through that perspective and say a few
intelligent things about it that's
that's pretty good for me that's not
mediocre but there are a lot of people
who are pretty mediocre the feel that
present I think that's often because
they just like only focus on this little
bit here and and there's there's quite a
few just also don't really have they
whatever the passion is that drives you
into philosophy they just don't have it
they just you know got into it and then
wound up being lucky enough in the
academic lottery to get a teaching
position
[Music]
Lukie where are we in contemporary times
in regards to dualism have we made any
progress how does that relate to the new
we are one movement which
appears to be little to the other
extreme I don't know if the new we are
one movement is but is there progress
yeah I mean I mean I think it's progress
that not too many people take
cartesianism and that includes Spinoza
by the way because who knows is a
Cartesian at first all that seriously
you know we learned some things along
the way but we tend to make the same
mistakes over and over again so you see
the same sort of positivistic stuff
getting bandied around is like oh this
is the new philosophy just they sprinkle
in neuroscience instead of the stuff
problem from you know the 1850s and
we're gonna keep making the same
mistakes cuz we're kind of a dumb
species that way especially the
intellectuals so all right Adam there's
a good point people underestimate the
power of just doing it should there any
be any limit of thinking before acting
we are there should be plenty of limits
of thinking before acting you you
probably should try to think out what
you're doing before you do it because
otherwise just doing it can whine mind
you up in all sorts of stuff that's how
you wake up you know like in bed with
with somebody
the next morning wondering where the
hell you are and how the hell you got
there and who the hell this person is
you know around Bart when you would just
just did it around bar time people do
those sorts of things it's not just in
movies so there's all sorts of things
where we should actually exercise some
prudence I think that that what's
important is that we not be like sort of
hyper intellectual but we find good ways
to integrate action and thinking and
remember thinking is an action to so
Andre what do you think of Montaigne I
like Miguel de Montaigne and he's kind
of interesting and and you know he's one
of the people if I ever do get around or
like writing a sort of a history of
anger he's got a great essay on that
Daniel asked one of my personal
strengths records I don't have those I
don't keep track of that sort of stuff I
don't care at all about that you know I
never even did when I was working out
as a young man because I was in doing
endurance lifting not trying to do
powerlifting right
and Durin's lifting is where you do long
sets many of them medium weights you're
never trying to max anything out you
know I would actually spend on my armed
arm and chest days you know I would
actually spend an hour doing a bench
pyramid with that but I never got
anywhere near trying to max anything out
i I knew that is like you know I'm not
gonna say it's it's just pure [ __ ]
right but it's it's kind of like getting
the cart before the horse you know the
goal is to have a strong healthy body
it's not about trying to set records or
anything like that all right let's see
here about Garrett says why does
Kierkegaard believe Christianity
discovered something other religions
have not Kirk Rio doesn't really talk
much about other religions for one thing
but but he does he does think that
Christianity introduces something new to
through the world you know it's in part
through the the intercessor right
probably the one of the best places to
go look for this the discussion of that
is the philosophical fragments the
discussion between the you know the
Socrates figure and who's doing about as
much as you can do just humanly and then
the you know the Redeemer figure who
intrudes the intrusion of the internal
into the temporal and teaches stuff that
goes beyond could you not adapt adopt
that adapt that into other religious
perspectives like say Buddhism I think
you could probably the Kierkegaard does
it just doesn't do that okay so nimi has
a thing about the Marx thing there are
many marks monuments in Germany and new
and has recently been made for his June
8th birthday
many people are storming that Marx and
his ideas are responsible for the deaths
of one one hundred million people well I
mean I'd say Stalin is more responsible
for that I'd say Mao's more as
before that wouldn't you I mean you can
you didn't find all sorts of ideas and
hold people accountable in kind of
tenuous ways you know was with Stalin
sort of faithful to Marx's perspective I
don't know what have you read Marx
because I I you know I don't see a lot
of genuine Marxist praxis in Stalinism I
know the Stalinist at the time claimed
that but their claims are always tenuous
and being combated by other Marxist who
are like this is kind of [ __ ] but I
this isn't something I actually have to
have a position on myself
well Petros what advice would you give
to someone who'll start studying
philosophy in university with the hope
of becoming a university professor the
biggest bit of advice get used to
rejection and disappointment because
it's tough to get a position and you got
to do a lot of work jump through a lot
of arbitrary Hoops and you may still not
get a position unfortunately I do have a
video out there advice about you know
becoming a university professor that you
can take a look at everything that I
said in there is you know stand by it
today so all right take care I feel
perfect in God's image I've reached
every goal I wished for I asked for when
I think of myself mind body soul love
myself tell myself I'm thankful for me
well that's like we say good work if you
can get it all right so that's good
written have you glanced that never
glanced at ancient Indian texts such as
Adi Shankara view on the self his school
of thought is greatly awoken the non
dualist months yeah so we're talking
about Vedanta here right and yeah I've
read ancient Indian texts I've taught
them in classes not for quite a while
but there's all sorts of non-dualism out
there so that that's good
and Kesey's you could say Hegel and
Epicurus were responsible for the
atrocities in Russia and China for their
influence on Marx
guess so I mean now we're getting to the
point of the ridiculous
and yeah holding Marc's accountable for
a hundred million deaths like holding
Adam Smith responsible for the Irish
potato famine you can find yeah so this
is a great point people who are going to
be you know I'm not just gonna say jerks
or [ __ ] or something like this
people are gonna be monsters moral
monsters to other people are going to do
so through whatever ideology they can
find Stalin would have been an [ __ ]
a terrible person whether he was in in
sort of Germany of the vemma or Republic
and got it you know drawn into say the
Nazi movement or whether he you know
found Marxism to be the vehicle for that
sort of thing
most of those sorts of people it's not
just you know the influence of those
ideas and they're acting like puppets
they are horrible people and you could
say what is it what is it about you know
some ideas or ideologies that allows it
but it's always much more than that it's
always like the social matrix and and
you know it's it's very easy to do this
well so and this is responsible for this
it's not such a direct conclusion most
of the time really BK well I consider do
morning literature lectures like the
Kafka videos yeah certainly well one of
their current lit writers do you enjoy
well you know I've been doing the
science fiction and fantasy sequence for
quite a while and you can see quite you
know a lot of people I enjoy with that
I've been meaning to do stuff on uh not
just Kafka but Dostoevsky that that's
actually by the way in there for the
patreon goals you know eventually I'm
going to restart doing videos in that
existentialism series once I've reached
a certain level of support because that
is what allows me to have the free time
not to be hustling after client
appointments and things like that to be
able to do more video work and now
podcast work as well so yeah
all right take care my husband is a
professor has worked as an his
electrician know right and gas fitter
good dad we all have quirks I think it
is I know what you mean he went white
here involved in as phony as no
addictions yeah my you know my adoptive
dad actually started going white in his
teens I think and by the time that he
died at 36 it was all white and yeah so
yeah it's interesting
III would rather take classes I think
this bit off topic I would rather take
classes with somebody who's actually got
some outside the Academy life experience
I probably rather take classes from
somebody who didn't come up with in
elite institutions then then you know
rather take him with people who like you
know went to more MORE down homey
institutions and had to fight forgetting
the positions that they did because you
probably get more out of it I don't know
it's just me all right Daniel asked this
on a video do you think saying God acts
as efficient cause within secondary
causality of Jesus's resurrection
reduces God to a being instead of being
itself I don't even work in that frame
of metaphysics this is you know so I
don't really have an answer to that
quite frankly it's not something I've
given much thought to for years and
years and years
alright I'm gonna take one more Thomas
with Malley's is a dumb to justify not
getting in the job getting a job for the
summer with philosophy being genuine in
the high daguerreian sense or something
like that I mean I don't think that this
has anything to do with Heidegger and
authenticity if you want a job in the
summer and a job is available you choose
whether you take on the job or not if
you have other priorities you deal with
those things I you know I don't see this
as something that requires
it's really a matter of your what you
want to do and your finances more than
anything else I don't think that this
requires any practical philosophy to to
decide I mean I'll tell you I work
year-round I take very few vacations I
do some academic teaching and that's
sort of feast or famine I'll be teaching
four classes next semester for three
different institutions one of them
online two of them right here in
Milwaukee fortunately just blocks away
but you know a gig is a gig you have to
decide whether it's good for you or not
so all right I'm gonna sign off we're
about 20 minutes over I want to spend
some time with over the rest of the
weekend with my kids before I take them
back to their their home and won't see
him again until July so great questions
everybody we didn't actually talk that
much about the body I think but we had a
lot of good questions and and comments
so thanks for all of that thanks to my
my patreon supporters and hope you guys
have a great Father's Day weekend